[Music]
Matt and I talked a lot about his script
which was very fully realized and where
Edward came from I do quite a bit of
backstory work for myself as an actor
and I think I told you something about
something I saw in my head and my memory
is you were like that should be a comic
and I was like oh my God that's that
would be amazing you should totally do
that and then I called actually Jim Lee
like the next day like but Paul has an
idea to do this comic and I think he
should just do it with kind of a riddler
origin comic from the movie so to really
geek out about Batman and the history it
just it really like gripped me the idea
here was to enter the comic in a really
subjective way so a lot of this is about
somebody like Edward Ashton and what is
going on inside his head and I always
felt like the only positive affirmation
Edward nation has ever gotten in his
entire life was from solving riddles or
playing games it's become its own thing
as since progresses and along with my
collaboration with my artist Devon Subic
who's been who's been wonderful working
with Paul was just amazing I love to go
on Creative searches you know and
different people are different about
that and he's always searching he's
always so creative but I'm dying to see
what this is I cannot wait to read it
[Music]